the clark county fire department has
taken the lead on the investigation into
the explosion at a boulder city business
where six employees were injured in that
blast at arma rock palmeri country
concrete earlier this week we're told
the county's hazmat team has been there
to assess hazardous material at the
scene and employees say the facility is
closed for the time being now out of
those six employees injured one was
severely hurt by the blast that's right
and today for the first time victoria
saha spoke with that employee who
describes the destruction
the employee that was closest to the
blast had severe burns and was rushed to
umc trauma from his hospital bed he
tells me he was determined to live i was
standing there looking down on my arms
watching my skin melt
thirty-two-year-old eddie diganji
describes a normal working day quickly
turning into horror this is life or
death
that's that's the first thing i thought
and i said i'm not dying diganji was
working on his machine at the concrete
facility when suddenly i felt the
explosion i saw it in front of me
it blew me a few feet back
conscious the whole time he took off his
burning clothes and tried to find the
nearest exit where his wife nikki
diganji who works in the same facility
was frantically looking for him i heard
the explosion and it shook everything
and i heard
screaming
and i just told myself i i hope that's
not eddie i hope it's not him
and
as i listened i was like oh my god i
think it is colleagues started pouring
water all over the ganges as the
ambulance arrived i just wanted the
burning to stop once at the hospital he
was met by his distraught mom first
thing he said his mom quit being a
crybaby but it's hard just
picturing him you know in pain i i have
no idea
how i'm even alive right now it needs a
walking miracle diganji still has a long
road to recovery doctors believe he'll
be here at umc trauma for about a month
the family has set up a gofundme to help
with any expenses we have that link up
on our website at 8newsnow.com
victoria saha live local now